العالم
المجاهد ابن
الشام الذي اعتلى منبر مسجد الاستقلال في
حيفا وخاض غمار
الجهاد ضد الانتداب البريطاني والعصابات
الصهيونيه ونحن
نفخر بان احد المكونات الاساسيه
والراسخ في مسيره الحركه ومسيره الجهاد
على ارض فلسطين هم من
العلماء
الابرار ومنهم من ارتقى شهيدا في ميادين
الجهاد وفي ميادين
الرباط على ارض
فلسطين وفي غزه وفي القدس وفي رحاب المسجد
الاقصى
المبارك
ايها الاخوه الكرام اخواتي
الكريمات اود هنا ان
اتحدث امام
حضراتكم
ونحن في حضره العلماء
والشهداء والعلماء ورثه
الانبياء
والشهداء والشهاده
هي احد اهم خصائص هذه
الامه فالا
الاسلاميه المجيده خصائصها
كثيره
وذروته هذه الخصائص انها امه
الشهاده امه
الشهداء منذ ذاك
العهد برسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
والصحب الكرام وفي كل محطات وتاريخ هذه
الامه ولذلك ليس
غريب ان
يكون غالبيه الصحابه رضي الله تعالى
عنهم قد دفنوا خارج المدينه وخارج مكه
وخارج الجزيره العربيه
ربما
لانهم كانوا يقودون
الفتوحات وكانوا رواد
للجهاد فلقوا الله سبحانه وتعالى
شهداء ودفنوا
بعيدا في بلاد الاسلام وبلاد
الفتوحات هذه امه الشهاده وامه
الجهاد والعلماء
هم المداد
والدماء كانوا وما
زالوا وهم
الرواد
وهم الذين يوقدون في الامه كل معاني
الصحوه الايمانيه
والجهاد ولذلك الله سبحانه وتعالى خاطب
نبيه بقوله قال فقاتل في سبيل الله لا
تكلف الا
نفسك وحرض
المؤمنين عسى الله ان يكف باس الذين كفروا
والله اشد باسا واشد
تنكيلا واريد ان اتحدث هنا
امامكم وامام جموع هذه
الامه وخلال هذه الملحمه
البطوليه التي تسطرها فلسطين عامه وغزه
على وجه
الخصوص في
عدد من
النقاط
اولها لماذا كان طوفان
الاقصى
لماذا كان هذا الطوفان
الهادر هذا التحول الاستراتيجي في
مسار المقاومه
والجهاد واجابه على
ذلك
اقول هناك
ثلاث هناك ثلاث تطورات سبقت طوفان
الاقصى سبقت السابع من
اكتوبر التطور الاول هو تهميش القضيه
الفلسطينيه على مستوى
العالم العالم المجتمع
الدولي دوائر صناعه القرار العالمي لم
تعد تستحضر قضيه
فلسطين و بدا العالم
يتعامل مع ان هذه قضيه ذات شان صهيوني
داخلي يعالجها
بطريقته لا قرارات دوليه لا
مؤتمرات حتى الحديث عن حل الدولتين بين
قوسين هذا الحديث لم يعد متداولا عند صناع
القرار في
العالم تهميش كامل
للقضيه
والتطور
الثاني هو انه
جاء في قلب الكيان الصهيوني حكومه خطيره
ومتطرف دينيا
وقوميا ووضعت على راس اولوياتها حسم معركه
القدس
والاقصى وتهويد الضفه
الغربيه واستمرار ح صار
غزه بل
والتفكير بتنفيذ مخططات
التهجير لشعبنا سواء من الضفه الى الاردن
او من غزه الى
مصر وهذه
الحكومه هي انعكاس
لواقع
التطرف الديني والقومي للمجتمع الاسرائيلي
ذاته
ولذلك بدات هذه الحكومه بتنفيذ
المخططات وراينا ما الذي جرى في المسجد
الاقصى
المبارك وراينا ما الذي يجري في الضفه
الغربيه من بناء المستوطنات وتهويد
الضفه وتقطيع
اوصالها وحصار
غزه غزه المحاصره منذ 17 سنه
واستمرار اعتقال الالاف من الاسرى
الفلسطينيين وكان واضح
لدينا ان هذه
الحكومه بامتدادات داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي انها ستعمل على هدم المسجد
الاقصى
المبارك او على الاقل بفرض السياده
الاسرائيليه الكامله على المسجد اولى
القبلتين ومصرى رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم واما التطور الثالث
الخطير هو عمليه الانزال السياسي خلف
الخطوط من خلال
التطبيع
ودمج الكيان الاسرائيلي في
المنطقه والتعامل معه ككيان
شرعي على
حساب القضيه والحقوق
والثوابت ثوابت الامه وثوابت
الشعب وهذا تطبيق لنظريه
اسرائيليه تقول ببناء سلام
اقليمي على حساب القضيه
الفلسطينيه ووصل قطار التطبيع الى العديد
من العواصم
ووصل الحديث بالتطبيع الى عواصم مركزيه في
المنطقه
ولذلك نحن امام هذه التطورات التي كانت
تعني تهميش القضيه
عالميا وتصفيه قضيه
فلسطين بفعل وجود هذه الحكومه
الصهيونيه ثم هذ الدخول الى المنطقه وبناء
التحالفات العسكريه
والامنيه
بحيث يتواجد الكيان في قلب هذه
التحالفات بالتاكيد ان شعبنا الفلسطيني
ومقاومتنا وفي مقدمتها حماس مع كل فصائل
المقاومه بالتاكيد ان
واقع بهذا الشكل لا يمكن ان تجابه
بالطريقه
الاعتياديه وبالوسائل
الكلاسيكيه
وبالمقابل عليهم الباب فاذا دخلتموه فانكم
[تصفيق]
غالبون فكان طوفان
الاقصى
هذا اليوم المجيد ليس فقط في تاريخ شعبنا
بل بتاريخ
الامه بل بتاريخ الانسانيه
جمعاء بتاريخ الانسانيه جمعاء كان طوفان
الاقصى هذه النقطه
الاولى النقطه
الثانيه هو ان العدو فعل ما يفعل الان في
غزه وكما ذكر الساده العلماء الكرام بوصف
ما يجري في
غزه ولكن هناك ثلاث اهداف او ثلاثه اهداف
رسمها العدو لنفسه من بدايه هذه الحرب
وهذا
العدوان
الاول القضاء على حركه حماس يعني القضاء
على
المقاومه
وانهاء المقاومه وسحق المقاومه في
غزه والهدف
الثاني هو
استرداد الاسرى
الموجودين عند القسام وكتائب وفصائل
المقاومه والهدف الثالث الخطير هو
تنفيذ خطه التهجير من قطاع غزه وتفريغه
باتجاه الاراضي
المصريه
هذه الاهداف الثلاث او
الثلاثه اهداف
معلنه تبنتها حكومه الحرب والحكومه
الموسعه وتبنتها الاداره الامريكيه
والتحالف
الغربي ونقول ذلك بكل جلاء هذه المعركه
وهذه الحرب وهذا
العدوان يمكن هذه المره مش بس عدوان
اسرائيلي امريكي على شعبنا وعلى غزه لا
عدوان امريكي
اسرائيلي لما بتيجي الاداره الامريكيه بكل
مكوناتها الى
المنطقه وترسم هي خطه الحرب
وتصفيه المقاومه نعرف شو معناه وابعاد هذه
المعركه التي تدور اليوم على ارض
غزه فهذه هي الاهداف
واستخدموا كل هذه القوه وهذا العدوان وهذه
الوحشيه وهذه
النازيه
اخواني
اخواتي اكثر من 70 الف طن من المتفجرات
نزلت على
غزه هذه توازي قنابل ذريه كتلك التي نزلت
على هروشيما ونكازاكي
وغزه 365 م م
مربع ودخل العدو واحنا نقترب اليوم من من
100 يوم تقريبا لهذا العدوان وهذه الوحشيه
وهذا القتل وهذا
التدمير دخل وهو يرسم اربع مراحل لهذه
الحرب المرحله الاولى القصف
الجوي
الشامل المرحله الثانيه الدخول البري
وتفكير باحتلال القطاع والمرحله الثالثه
التي يسميها مرحله العمليات الجراحيه
المركزه ضد المقاومه وقياداتها
واركانها والمرحله الرابعه هي المرحله
السياسيه اللي بيتكلموا فيها غزه بعد حماس
واليوم التالي للحرب بلا
مقاومه هذهه مراحل الحرب المرسومه على
قطاعنا وعلى
فلسطين السؤال
اليوم بعد 100 او ما يقرب من 100 يوم على
هذه
الحرب ونقول بفضل الله هل حقق العدو ايا
من اهدافه
العسكريه
المعلنه اقول لكم ايها الاخوه ايتها
الاخوات رغم الثمن الكبير
[تصفيق]
والباهظة حماس
ارهابيه حماس ارهابيه كل العالم حمساويه
كل العالم حمساويه قاله حماس ارهابيه قاله
حماس ارهابيه كل العالم حمساويه كل العالم
حسيه قالوا ذلك بدهم يقضوا على حماس في
غزه هي حماس في
غزه هي مش حماس في الضفه هي حماس مش كل
فلسطين
هي حماس مش كل الشعب الفلسطيني في المنافي
والشتات هي حماس مش ضمير امه هي حماس مش
من نداء احرار
العالم
اليوم ومكروا ومكر الله والله خير
الماكرين الله
اكبر ونريد ان نمن على الذين استضعفوا في
الارض ونجعلهم
ائمه ونجعلهم
الوارثين
ولذلك اليوم ما في بيت في العالم مش بس في
العالم الاسلامي ما في بيت في
الكون الا وكلمه حماس دخلت الى هذا
البيت الاخبار
اللغات ما
في اي بيت اليوم او اي اسره في اي جهه في
العالم في القارات الست الا بسمع الاخبار
غزه حماس فلسطين القدس المقاومه المجازر
المذابح مصداقا لقول الله سبحانه وتعالى
يريدون ليطفئوا نور الله
بافواههم يريدون ليطفئوا نور السلاح
والمقاومه وصواريخ القسام ويابى الله الا
ان يتم
نوره ولو كره الكافرون
فاطمئنوا هذا كلام
وسراب اما هدف ان يستردوا
اسراهم بعد 100 يوم فشل الجيش
والقوه
والاستخبارات والطائرات الغربيه التي جاءت
فوق غزه اليوم طائرات التجسس احدث طائرات
التجسس من دول غربيه اليوم فوق قطاع غزه
بتبحث عن
الاسرى ولكنهم لم يستطيعوا ان ي رد اسير
واحد الا بما قبلته
المقاومه وفق الاتفاق الذي جرى حينما تم
الاتفاق على
الهدنه ونقول
اليوم ما حيسترد
اسراهم
مطلقا الا بالافراج عن كل اسرانا من سجون
الاحتلال لذلك فشلوا في هذا
الموضوع وحتى العمليات المركزه والاستخبار
المدعومه عسكريا اللي بدها تروح تنقذ اسير
بتقتله
والمجاهدين بيحتفظ
به ومن شده الهلع
والاضطراب ثلاثه منهم طلعوا خالعين
ملابسهم رافعين ال الفانيلات البيضاء
كاتبين بالعبري لانه هذول الجنود ب يطلعوا
باتجاه الجيش الجيش قتلهم واعتقد انه هذه
عمليه خداع استراتيجي من
القسام لذلك فشلوا في هذا
الموضوع
و جرت مفاوضات برعايه الاشقاء في
قطر والاشقاء في مصر وبمتابعة
الموقف
واضح بلا تردد واما هدف
التهجير
فايضا سقط هذا
الهدف سقط هذا
الهدف اولا لانه الشعب الفلسطيني منغرس في
ارضه لن
نكرر نكبه ال
48 لن نخرج من
ارضنا بل منزرع في الارض وهذه غزه انتم
ملاحظين وشايفين
مجازر مذابح قتل مسح عائلات
بالكامل في عائلات بالكامل مسحت من السجل
المدني اكثر من 450 عائله اكبر من 10
افراد جميعها
استشهد
بالكامل يا اخوان في عائلات والعائلات
كثيره فيها
شهيد عائلات 192
شهيد ومع ذلك بيطلع من تحت الانقاض من
تبقى منهم ليقول فداى فلسطين وفدى القدس
وفدى المقاومه وفدى
الكرامه ومش بس
هم بدهم يطلعوا الناس لما
سمح بعوده العالقين من ابناء غزه اللي
موجودين
بالخارج سمح لهم بالعوده الى غزه العالقين
اللي في خارج غزه دخلوا غزه وليس الذين في
غزه خرجوا
[تصفيق]
منها لذلك اقول لكم ايها الاخوه الكرام
والاخوات الكريمات هذا العدو فشل فشلا
ذريعا في تحقيق اي من اهدافه العسكريه نجح
في شيء نجح
انه كشف وجهه الدموي القبيح
القاتل وهو يرتكب هذه
المجازر اليوم ما في حدا في العالم الا
ويعرف هذا الكيان لانه حاولوا يمرر انه
هذا كيان ديمقراطي وهذه دوله ديمقراطيه
وهذا جيش اخلاقي لا
اليوم طوفان الاقصى
كشف اللثام للعالم اجمع عن طبيعه هذا
الكيان لا اخلاقي ولا ديمقراطي ولا
قيمي بل ما يفعله يشهده ويشاهده العالم
اجمع اما النقطه
الثالثه وقبل الاخيره التي ساختم
بها
كيف هو توصيف الواقع
اليوم والحال وكيف نتعامل
معه
اخواني غزه اليوم تقاتل على
جبهتين وفلسطين لانه نعم مركز الان
الاحداث في
غزه لحجم هذه المواجهه لكن ما يجري في
الضفه الغربيه
ايضا شيء ايضا خطير
وكبير العدو ينكل باهلنا في الضفه
الغربيه وعننا اكثر من 350 شهيد في الضفه
الغربيه منذ بدايه طوفان الاقصى واقتحامات
يوميه وعلى المدن واعدامات
وقتل وبالامس فقط بالامس سبعه شهداء في
جنين اربعه منهم
اشقاء ووقفت
امهم كالخنساء التي فقدت الاربعه
وسمعها العالم ورباطه الجاش وابناؤها
الاربعه شهداء امامها رباطه
الجاش الايمان ولذلك ما يجري في الضفه وفي
القدس وفي
الاقصى تحت
ظلال العدوان والحرب على غزه شيء ليس سهل
ايضا ونتابع ذلك ايها الاخوه والاخوات
وحتى في ال
48 اهلنا في ال 48 الذين اعلنوا تطبيق
الاحكام العسكريه العرفيه
عليهم من بدايه معركه وحرب ومعركه طوفان
الاقصى فضلا عن شعبنا الفلسطيني اللي في
المنافي والشتات فغزا تقاتل على
جبهتين الجبهه
العسكريه فصائل المقاومه القسام السرايا
كل فصائل
المقاومه وهذه
جبهه
قويه ثابته
متماسكه توقع كل يوم بل كل ساعه الخسائر
في جيش العدو
الغازي وما يقوله الاحتلال اليوم وما
يعترف
به من قتلى او
جرحى ليس هو الحقائق الحقائق ترسم في
الميدان حتى
الفيديوهات اللي
بيشاهدو العالم اجمع عن عمليات المقاومه
والقسام وفصائل المقاومه برضو هي فيديوهات
اعدادها قليله مقارنه لما يجري في
الميدان لانه مش كل العمليات بتتصور مش كل
العمليات بتطلع
فيديوهات لكن الاحتلال وجيش الاحتلال يعرف
الحقائق والخسائر
ويمكن بقدر الله عشيه هذا المؤتمر امس
الاعلام الاسرائيلي يقول بانه امبارح امس
كان اصعب يوم في الحرب علينا في
غزه انظروا اخواني بعد ما يقرب من 100 يوم
بيجي بيتكلم عن ايام
صعبه لان هناك رجال صدقوا ما عاهدوا الله
عليه يطاردونه في كل جبهات ومحاور
القتال هم اللي بيطلعوا
له
يقاتلونه
يتصيدون هذا الجيش المحتل
الغازي ولذلك هذه الجبهه هي جبهه قويه
متماسكه
واعده نفسها طويل
لديها حاسيه استراتيجيه عاليه خطه تحكم
سيطره
قياده وهذا الامر هو مبعث فخر لكل ابناء
هذه الامه واحرار
العالم والجبهه الثانيه التي تقاتل عليها
غزه اليوم هي الجبهه المدنيه
الانسانيه وذكر فضيله الدكتور همام في
كلمته الوصف للواقع انساني وما اشار اليه
فضيله الدكتور علي والاخوه الكرام واخي
بولند الوضع الانساني وضع كارثي بكل ما
تعنيه الكلمه من
معنى
ولذلك امام هذان هذين الجبهتين او هاتين
الجبهتين لهم في قلب المواجهه الجبهه
العسكريه والجبهه الامنيه دور الامه دور
كبير
ودور علماء الامه دور محوري على
الجبهتين على جبهه دعم
المقاومه يا اخواني يا اخواتي العالم كله
بصب سلاح عند
الاحتلال العالم كله لا
يخشى
في جسور جويه من عواصم متعدده
بتصل الى الاحتلال وحاملات طائرات و ووالى
اخره
احنا هذا اصبح فرض
عين لما يقوم به وما يجب ان نقوم به وكما
اشار الساده العلماء هناك فتاوى وهناك
تحريض وهناك بيانات وهناك جها جهاد البيان
وجهاد اللسان نعم انا الاوان لجهاد السنان
الله اك الله
[تصفيق]
اكبر هذه معركه القدس
والاقصى وليست معركه غزه ومعركه الشعب
الفلسطيني او الاهل في غزه الاهل في غزه
خندق
متقدم
للدفاع وخندق متقدم
للهجوم ليس فقط للدفاع للهجوم هو 7 اكتوبر
شو هو الخندق المتقدم للهجوم لهذه
الامه وان الاوان الا تفلت منا هذه اللحظه
ايها الساده يا ابناء الامه يا احرار
العالم
قلما يجود الزمان بمثل هذه اللحظات
التاريخيه اياكم ان تفلت
منكم قلما يجود الزمان بمثل هذه
اللحظات التاريخيه
للامه ولعلماء
الكرام اياها اياكم ان تفلت منكم لانه اذا
فلتت لا ندري كم نحتاج من العقود حتى
تعود وان شاء الله لن
تفلت هذا هو العهد وهذا هو
الميثاق
واما النقطه
الرابعه
والاخيره ما العمل وماذا نريد بالتفصيل
وفق ما اشار اليه فضيله الدكتور علي خارطه
الطريق واليوم المنطقه كلها على صفيح
ساخن في جبهات المقاومه وشهداء من شعبنا
في لبنان
و شهداء من اشقائنا في لبنان ومن
غيرهم هناك جبهات مسانده وهناك اطارات
وهناك حراك
عالمي وهذا كله موضع تقدير واحترام
واعتزاز ولاحظوا اخواني الوقت يعمل
لصالحكم
ولصالح لانه في بدايه
العدوان كان في هناك يعني
عصا غليظه الامريكان يرفعوه في وجه العالم
وبعض الدول حتى
الجاليات الفلسطينيه العربيه المسلمه في
الدول في بعض الدول الاوروبيه استدعي
استدعي بعض يعني شخصياتها سواء كان من
فلسطينيه او عربيه وطلب منهم الا يرفعوا
علم فلسطين وطلب منهم الا يفعلوا
شيء ولكن هذه الدول ذاتها اليوم لغتها
تغيرت
لغتها تغيرت شو سبب تغيير هذه اللغه هو
الصمود
الصمود ولولا هذا الصمود
لسحق الضمير
العالمي
الصمود وهذا الصمود اخواني يجب ان نبني
عليه هذا الانتصار الذي جرى في السابع من
اكتوبر يجب ان نمسك به ونبني عليه ونراكم
عليه وهنا في النقطه
الاخيره ما العمل وماذا
نريد ادعو اخواني الكرام الى استحضار
الاتي
اولا اعلان الدوحه الذي سيتم الاعلان عنه
اعلان الدوحه حفظ الله الدوحه وحفظ الله
كل دولنا العربيه
والاسلاميه وبما يقومون
به اعلان الدوحه للتحالف الانساني هذا
امر
لافت
ومعبر ويشكل نقله
وبدايه واعده ان شاء الله ولكن هذا يحتاج
الى وضع برنامج وخطه
استراتيجيه واليات
عمل
حتى لا يقتصر على الاعلان
وفقط هذا اعلان مهم وبنحتاج الى وضع خطه
واليات وبرامج
وجدول
وتحرك على جميع المستويات في هذا
الاتجاه النقطه
الثانيه هو ان الساده
العلماء يمكن ان يشكلوا
فرق
ووفود على اكثر من
مستوى
وفود
تزور المسؤولين في الدوله ذاتها اللي هم
عايشين
فيها مسؤولين الدوله الاحزاب القوى
المجتمع المدني الم
مسات ويقوم بواجبهم في ال
دولتهم حتى بقياده
الجماهير قياده
الجماهير
و هذا الامر الاول الامر الثاني هو ايضا
تشكل وفود
متخصصه
لللقاء برؤساء
دول عربيه واسلاميه وحتى دول
غربيه وان انا
ادعو تكرما من الساده العلماء فضيله
الدكتور واخواننا الكرام ان يضعوا هذا
الامر على طاوله البحث تشكيل وفد علمائي
وازن لزياره العديد من
الدول وان يكون هذا الوفد وفد مفتوح
ووفد معبر ووفد يعكس كل هذا
الطيف
وزياره الدول والحديث حول فلسطين وحول
القدس وحول غزه وضروره وقف العدوان على
قطاع
غزه ثم الامر
الثاني
هناك دعوه الى التبرع
بالمال ونحن اخواني الكرام واخواتي
الكريمات لنطلق عليه الجهاد
المالي الامه لا
تتبرع مش
تبرعات هذا مش موضوع انساني
وفقط على اهميته وحاجه غزه لكل العون
ولكنه الجهاد
بالمال يجب ان نحيي هذا الفقه في
الامه فقه الجهاد بالنفس
والمال والله سبحانه وتعالى قال وجاهدوا
باموالكم
وانفسكم في سبيل الله
وهناك بعض اللطائف اللي قالت واما تعرضن
عنهم ابتغاء رحمه من ربك ترجوها فقل لهم
قولا
ميسورا يعني اذا انت ما بدك تعطي المحتاج
تعرض عنه فقل له قولا ميسورا ليش بدك تعرض
ان لا تعطي المحتاج لان هناك
اولويه هي تتعلق بان يذهب هذا المال لل
جهاد في سبيل الله قل قول ميسور هو ولكن
المال تعطيه
للاولويه لاولو
المرحله وهو الجهاد بالمال هذه من لطائف
هذه الايه واما تعرضن عنهم ابتغاء رحمه من
ربك
ترجوها واي رحمه ترجوها اعظم من رحمه
الجهاد والجهاد هو ذروه سنام الاسلام فل
نارد ان نحيي فقه ال الجهاد المالي وفقه
الجهاد نحن نستقبل وفود يوميه من كل ارجاء
الدنيا ومن كل ارجاء الامه الاسلاميه
جميعهم يتحدث بلغه واضحه ان الشباب اليوم
فقه الجهاد والحديث عن الجهاد وحسيه
الجهاد والمقاومه اصبحت
مغروسه من الذي يريد ان يستثمر
بناء الجيل الجهادي من اجل تحرير بيت
المقدس ولكي تمتزج دماء الامه مع دماء اهل
غزه ودماء القدس وفلسطين على ارض فلسطين
من اجل تحريرها وتحرير بيت المقدس الله
اكر ثم
اخواني انا ادعو ايضا ان يخرج عن هذا
المؤتمر مؤتمر الاقصى ودور الامه الى جانب
البيان الختامي رساله خاصه لاهل
غزه ولو
صفحه تخاطب بها اهل
غزه تضمد جراحهم
تواسو تشد على ايدي
مجاهد تؤكد لهم التزامات العلماء والامه
تجاههم رساله تصدر عن مؤتمر طوفان الاقصى
ودور الامه ويعبر عن دور الامه ان شاء
الله علمائها وامرا
ومصو وان يصدر هذا الامر بالنسبه لنا
ثم الدعوه نعم الى اغاثه اهل غزه
وتقديم المساعدات
بكل اشكالها وبكل الوانها وبكفه الطرق
وبكافة
لعوائل
الشهداء لعوائل الجرحى لعوائل
الاسرى الاسرى الابطال في سجون الاحتلال
الصهيوني اللي زاد عددهم الان عن 10 الاف
اسير لانه العدو اعتقل ما يقرب من حوالي
4500 اسير من بدايه طوفان الاقصى من
ابنائنا وشبابنا وبناتنا في الضفه
الغربيه تحيه لعوائل
الشهداء تحيه للجرحى الميامين للاسرى
الابطال تحيه للقابض على
الزناد تحيه
للمقاتلين الذين يدافعون عن شرف
الامه تحيه لكل جبهات
المقاومه التي تساند غزه
وفلسطين تحيه لكل ابناء هذه الامه ولكل
احرار
العالم الذي الين يقفون اليوم في موقف
الدفاع وموقف الاسناد وموقف التعزيز صمود
شعبنا وامتنا والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته